this lesson we're going to look at
thanks tracks now before we get started
on like what that is how to work with
them literally like what are they
weren't even me I just want you to
remember with me we're still in this
idea of circular motion now we did our
scheme of circular motion you've got two
kinds of velocity do you remember what
the two kinds are two kinds of ways of
describing how things moving okay so
number one you can talk about angular
momentum what was our name which looks a
whole lot like W and linear linear
velocity or tangential velocity which is
in this context mean the same thing okay
now remember on a circle Omega is about
the change in theater in time wait the
change in Peter so here's theater a
linear velocity by contrast is about the
change in this kind of arc length over
here so this is the owl on duty and L is
your artwork okay now in the context of
circular motions so far we've pretty
much been like Omega is where it's at
like everything almost everything has
been in terms of Omega in terms of
angular velocity okay so for instance
what we've been talking about forces and
the force that makes the circular motion
happen we've pretty much always been
talking about it in terms of Omega if we
say the for Solomon on ball is positive
outwards away from the center then
what's our normal expression out F
equals MA for uniform circular motion
what is it it's give you tips parts of
the negative because its water sent up
mr vegas way yeah very good yeah yeah
okay so very good however um on some
occasions including the one we're about
to look at now angular 2 is actually
something you know nothing about instead
it's linear momentum linear velocity
that you know about okay so what I'm
what I think about is if this is the
connection between these two right I've
got help equals according to Radian
measure in that circle L is equal to R
theta like so so therefore instead of
saying that the force is minus up mr
omega square right think about it this
way if l equals R fever then V is equal
to our event I've seen this before right
so I'm going to make a substitution in
here for Omega Omega is V on our reg fee
on top so i can write this in just the
same way as minus mr v on our sweat you
seen this before right so I can just
simply super find that a little bit and
here's a slightly different expression
these are both equivalent it's just that
this is going to be much more useful to
us if what we know is linear varsity
rather than anger blossom details okay
yeah this we need to be through there no
no no it's of the same it's not the same
umm Sami as this however I am going to
say like I always I always from have
this first and then I come to this it's
not a very big way and this way I know
whatever right so just to have that kind
of sort of follow the way in the back of
your mind and now let's think about a
car negotiating a turn on the road okay
I can't ago Shannon on the way now the
odd that this son rue it is on right it
kind of for this one that's traveling
along this earth the car is moving in
circular motion right which means that
for circular motion after knowing States
for circular motion to be happening
there has to be a resultant force in
what direction which direction will the
force before you they get back to
uniform circular motion
the force has to be going toward the
center of the circle that this arc is on
right is that it's like I mean this is
this presumably this is not just a
circular Road this is just a part of it
but it's like part of a circle while
we're on it there is some kind of Center
to which our forces are turning right
otherwise you're not going to be
changing direction as you go and the the
action force is this force right I don't
need to write because I've got arrows
here that indicate the direction of
what's going on just like I write mg and
then there's an arrow I'm not going to
write minus at me straight on our video
I'm just going to write MV squared on
that because that's the magnitude that
I'm interested in ok so this is the
direction of the force is going in in
order to make the term ok now we've been
looking at all kinds of different things
that make this some make this circular
motion happen the most frequently we've
been looking at is the tension in the
string but that's not the only thing
that can make a circular motion happen
for example moon ordering on earth
there's no string what's the force
that's sort of making this happen it's
gravity right now we've got it should be
the string it's been about the time in
the afternoon your attention industry or
our gravity what is the force that makes
this happen free here ok so you're in
the car right and you're turning the
wheel and your wheels are in contact
with the ground now it's friction that's
pushing in that way because you're
turning that way this is why if there's
radar right there are so many accidents
because rain means less friction between
your your tires and the road ok so
without friction if this is not actually
happening we don't have enough friction
to produce this resultant force then
what's going to happen if suddenly this
disappears think about the discus right
what's going to happen this guy's just
going to go he's going to skid off the
road ok he's not going to have
sufficient friction to maintain that
resultant force toward the
the center of the circle okay now this
is also why if you're on a turn if you
see if you've been out turns they have
speed limits did you know did you know
if you're wrong you're out yeah that's
right i'm going to show you one in a
second okay now here's why this equation
this equation tells us everything right
not all turns have speed limits speed
limits right or speed suggestions and
it's just a guideline i'm only some of
them do namely sharp turns okay now this
is actually a pretty sharp turn the one
that I've drawn on here now just look at
this expression this expression alone
tells you what's going on why is it what
can I say out of the expression tells me
why a sharp turn requires me to limit my
speed have a look think of that say it
again a bit louder though okay so you've
got the mass of your car you'd expect is
constant right velocity you can change
the radius is not just cluster on a
sharp turn the point is that the radius
is small right if the radius is small
because if the radius is life is like a
very wide turn if the radius is small
what is happening to this whole value
here yes yeah denominator gets smaller
the whole thing gets bigger so you
require extra force to keep you in right
now the less your ties are amazing
you're going to need to do this to
compensate so that's why you'll see
actually when they found it was stock
from photography so sorry that's why I
would have found this this is the kind
of thing you see right so there's the
turn and they're like look this is going
to be small right so therefore you'd
better make this small in sort of in
comparison especially because this is
being squared of course you do have one
alternative which is um if you if you do
want to decrease the mass of your car if
you could do that somehow
passenger out then that would have the
same effect which is why which is why if
you think about like say a truck or a
bus that kind of thing when are they if
you watch them make a turn right if
there is two lanes to turn from which
lanes you they shoot make sure is
getting out of way they choose the outer
mode so here they choose this laid over
here rather this led over here why what
are they doing what they doing yeah very
good they try to make this bigger right
because they don't want to throw out
some of their cargo so that means what
does it being like watch out for people
who might be no no way I Photoshop this
site I if I've got an actual sign like
that that'd be really hilarious and I'm
worried okay so part of the problem is
like this the reason why we have to do
this is because so far we've said
there's only a single force that
contributes in this direction namely
friction okay for example if we're going
to look at this rather than like top
down if we look at this like front on
okay which direction is the normal force
the reaction force which way is that
going and the answer it is it's sin
again okay you've got you on the ground
which presumably is flat right and so
you have the normal force coming
directly off which is vertical okay but
what if it wasn't